et on retrouve sur place stéphanie
benoît porte parole du collectif 93 anti
crack qui a évidemment participer à
cette manifestation ce soir bonsoir
stéphanie benoit merci d'être avec nous
on vient de le voir ces élus qui
demandent un entretien notamment en
urgence au premier ministre clairement
qu'attendez-vous des services de l'état
alors là on a appris aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qu'une réunion devait se
tenir demain avec des membres de l'état
la ville de paris le préfet de police et
préfet de paris
malheureusement les élus 1093 et
notamment les maires de pantin et
d'aubervilliers n'ont pas été consultés
n'ont pas été conviés
donc on regrette on le regrette
fortement et clairement
non attends tu sais ces réunions qu'elle
débouche sur une réelle solution pérenne
une prise en charge sanitaire et sociale
de ces de ces toxicomanes qui ne peuvent
plus errer dans les rues comme cela et
qu'ils ne peuvent plus être subir des
énièmes le déplacement comme comme ça a
été encore le cas vendredi alors
stéphanie benoit pour bien qu'on
comprenne un expliquez-nous d'ailleurs
ce que vous avez derrière vous ce fameux
mur le mur surnommé le mur de la honte
expliquez-nous votre quotidien le
quotidien des habitants
que vous représentez ce soir
alors le quotidien des habitants
aujourd'hui on compose avec une arrivée
de nouveaux visages de toxicomanes on en
connaissait déjà dans le quartier
aujourd'hui on compose avec des nouveaux
qui ne nous connaissent pas avec
lesquels on n'ait pas été apprivoisés
foncez pas apprivoiser si j'ose dire
ainsi
aujourd'hui on doit composer avec leur
toxicomanie avec leur leur addiction et
c'est là où ça les entraîne on se
retrouve à confrontée à des scènes de
violence
certaines font font font des témoignages
précisant qu'elles ont été victimes de
le gifle de coups de poings de vols déjà
même déjà dès vendredi dès leur arrivée
ce mur que cliquer juste derrière moi
lui alors il à la seule et unique
symbolique de de vouloir essayer de
diviser encore un peu plus le 93 du
territoire parisien en aucun cas ils
empêchent comme l'a évoqué monsieur
darmanin de de faire passer les deux les
toxicomanes sur le 93 puisque dans ce
cas là la porte de la villette aurait dû
dans ce cas être être murée et donc les
toxicomanes effectivement viennent sur
sur nos secteurs
s'installe dans l'ogoniland cage
d'escalier on commence à apprendre des
vols de voitures de différentes
violences et incivilités qui sont liées
à ces toxicomanes incarnant ce mur aussi
que l'on distingue bien ça empêche aussi
beaucoup de riverains qui faisait
peut-être aller retour notamment à vélo
pour éviter les gros bouchons de porte
de la chapelle de de circuler
aujourd'hui c'est évidemment un handicap
pour les personnes du quartier on
imagine
alors effectivement certains certains
pans tinois essentiellement puisque le
mur est construit sur sur la ville de
pantin certains parents qui faisaient ce
qu'ils lisent et ce passage pour se
raccourcir le trajet se dirige en
direction de la porte de la villette bon
ben maintenant ils sont obligés
d'utiliser
l'avenue jean jaurès et la porte de la
villette directement c'est vrai que
c'est regrettable parce que du coup ça
les oblige à
revoir leur itinéraire nous aussi en
tant qu albertivillariens obligés de
revoir nos itinéraires parce que là où
sont implantées désormais les
toxicomanes c'est à ciel ouvert s'est il
ya aucune fermeture et ils vont viennent
comme ils veulent on les retrouve à se
battre sur les trottoirs donc des
trottoirs qui sont normalement utilisés
par les riverains de pantin et
d'aubervilliers pour se rendre au métro
on comprend c'est que c'est un problème
sans fin puisque ça fait des années que
ça dure dans le 19e avant on a déplacé
donc ce problème faire chez vous alors
chacun évidemment il va de sa
proposition gérald darmanin qui dès
qu'ils assurent que cette situation
serait temporaire le garde des sceaux
qui déclarent travailler très
sérieusement sur la question épineuse du
crack à paris valérie pécresse ol qui
veut des centres de désintoxication
clairement nous avait encore toute
confiance aux autorités quelque bord
qu'elles soient
alors c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui on
se demande qu'est ce qui bloque parce
que on a entendu dire que la région
avait apporté son soutien financier on a
entendu dire que la ville de paris avait
trouvé des structures afin d'aider des
endroits pour pour développer ce genre
de structure et pourtant aujourd'hui on
voit pas d'issue envoyée il ya il n'y a
rien qui se met en place il ya rien de
concret donc on se demande vraiment où
est l élément bloquant qu'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui a rien qui soit
proposée pour justement à prendre en
charge ces personnes et pour avoir été
moins en contact avec deux d'entre eux
la les 5 derniers jours
ça reste des humains qui disent eux même
avoir la nécessité de s'isoler les uns
les autres
aujourd'hui on se pose aussi la question
et c'était bien le point on voit égalité
1989 on imagine voilà que les habitants
de seine-saint-denis
prennent ça comme une forme
d'humiliation tout simplement pourquoi
avoir choisi ce quartier
c'est a été justifiée par le
gouvernement par roger halderman a
alors le
le mine de ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur darmana évoqué effectivement
qu'il n'y avait pas de riverains dans ce
quartier il n'ya pas effectivement de
riverains directs sur le square de la
porte de la villette néanmoins il ya
dérivant à moins de 100 mètres donc
c'est complètement faux de dire qu'il
n'y a pas de riverains puisque on puisse
nous sommes tous usagers de cet endroit
pour comprendre à lohan au travail
respectif donc c'est vraiment cessé pris
comme un coup de poignard parce que on a
l'impression que les âmes qui vivent
derrière le périph n'existe pas aux yeux
du gouvernement et et et que l'on
connaît déjà déjà beaucoup de
difficultés et on se dit que c'est
impossible qu on nous rajoute des
problèmes à ses difficultés lesquels on
essaie déjà de sortir la tête de l'eau
merci en tout cas et on rappelle
justement que le quartier des quatre
chemins étaient hôtels classés quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
la petite information
ironique merci en tout cas avoue
stéphanie benoit d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour ce
témoignage